[Applaudissements]
il est difficile pour ceux qui ont eu de
mention au bac s vos chances sont de 2%
connais la différence 4 un étudiant en
médecine un étudiant en prépa demandeurs
d'apprendre le breton parker l'étudiant
préfailles te demandera pourquoi
l'étudiant en médecine pour quand
commence le matin par une matière
difficile puis pause dej 40 minutes une
matière facile l'après midi jusqu'à 17
heures pause goûter 20 minutes on
enchaîne avec deux heures du mat hier
difficile et le soir on fait des
analyses que ce qu'on se préoccupe
à ce rythme là se jouait sur du bois tél
15 heures pour tout donné 15 jours pour
tout revoir sa carrure plus sage de gif
le mieux faire des annales franchement
faut qu'on devienne des machines à
répondre aux questions
femme ça
phobies comme états
razer pour répondre à 72 questions avec
cinq réponses au choix ça fait environ
deux minutes par question donc à ce
rythme là c'est impossible de réfléchir
soit on répond par réflexe reptilien
soit au hasard je pense que les
meilleurs enfin ceux qui deviendront
médecins se rapproche plus du reptile
que de l'être humain je vais être
médecin 5
il a complètement pété un plomb a
carrément basket une place en plus je
passais 20
j'avais faim avec toi c'est toi
peut-être trop de retard en ce moment
depuis la jeune emma une pause ouais
carrément aux maths à les dérivés stats
intégral